okay so we're going to do an experiment
today that Martin Polyakov has been on
us to do for a while so we finally
finally going to get it get around to
doing it he's very excited about it and
what we're going to talk about is is a
deuterium oxide okay
so GT reom oxide is often referred to as
heavy water
most elements exist in more than one
form which are chemically identical but
where the atoms weigh different amounts
and the difference between these
different forms which are called
isotopes is by far the biggest for
hydrogen so it's heavy water so water is
h2o as which are everyone knows and G
Tyrion oxide is d 2o so hydrogen
normally has one proton but a second
form of hydrogen called deuterium has
Neutron as well the neutron has the same
mass as the proton but is electrically
neutral it doesn't have a positive or
negative charge the proton has a
positive charge so you can add this
without affecting the atom you still
have just one electron so it's just like
hydrogen but now you can see it weighs
twice as much so hydrogen is just proton
with a little electron buzzing around it
if you like NGT reom is a proton and a
neutron with an electron buzzing around
it in the universe and on the earth
about one atom in every seven thousand
of hydrogen is in this heavy for
deuterium this means that if you are an
average weight our belt of about 70
kilos and making the assumption of about
how much water is in your body somewhere
between 6 to 8 grams of the water in
your body is in fact heavy water which
contains deuterium instead of hydrogen
Niels dug out a really old school sample
of deuterium oxide so I like I like the
box I finally worked out how to how to
open it which is good and what we have
is a really really old school song but
look at the writing it's all kind of
like on the list 1930s writing or
something I'm not quite sure how old it
is but it's so in really old Psalm of
DTO and it's sealed in a glass ampule so
that so that it kind of remains as it is
in there where do you get all that stuff
yeah so you can imagine water which is
h2o
has these heavier atoms of hydrogen
which have their own chemical symbol so
instead of being h2o it's now d2o and
you can also and as in your body what
you will have is just one hydrogen and
one deuterium because you've got so much
water and the hydrogen's and the yolks
the hydrogens and the deuteriums can
just switch around between one molecule
another they feel really careful and do
a careful separation process you can get
pure D to O so today's grand experiment
is we're going to make while we've made
some ice cubes with normal water and
some ice cubes with D to O okay so we
got an ice cube tray which we're going
to dig out in a minute
and we've actually just made some normal
ice cubes and what we're going to do is
it's an experiment I've never I've never
actually done before and we're going to
see if the obviously you know that water
to ice because it's less dense than
water actually floats in water and we're
going to look to see if we make D to Oh
ice cubes where they will float in the
water or not because dose of deuterium
oxide is a bit denser than water
heavier D does not appear on the
periodic table but deuterium is used so
much in all sorts of chemical
experiments that it has its own simple
in fact there is a third form of
hydrogen which has two neutrons so it's
weight of three units called tritium
which has a simple tea but tritium is
radioactive so it's not used very widely
unless you're trying to make nuclear
weapons and that's another story what we
need to do first and is we need to get
rid of all the eggs obviously is a lot
of air dissolved in indeed in d2o in
anything and so neil has degassed some
d2o and some water for us so this is a
vacuum pump here and what you can do is
apply a vacuum to said liquid and pump
out all of the air out of the out of the
liquid so we're degassing it
there we go so what happened was that
the the air basically started to almost
if you like boil out of the water for a
long time I can't remember how long but
more than 30 years it has always struck
me that ice solid water is about ten
percent lighter than all the liquid
water that's why ice floats at the top
of your drink or floats on the top of
the pond in your garden okay so what we
did was he made some ice cubes with the
D gas water so these are the water ice
cubes the colorless ones and what we did
with the DTO ones just so we could see
the difference is we put a little tiny
bit of food coloring only a small amount
so it shouldn't affect the experiment at
all but just so we can see the
difference okay so what we need to do
now is filiz because with waters we'll
get some water the question is since d
2o is of 10% heavier than h2o heavy ice
solid d 2o should be just about the same
density all but slightly heavier than
liquid water so it might be that heavy
ice should sink in liquid water in let
ordinary water and I've always wondered
what happens and I've never been able to
do the experiment the one going to do is
I hope this works
Papa D - Oh ice cube in here and I'm
hoping it sinks yeah I think that's sunk
I now know that my colleagues have done
it but I have no idea what happens my
prediction and I've done lots of
calculations is that it'll just sink but
I might be wrong I might have gotten to
include something in my calculation so
what we've got is we've got ice in water
here and ice is less dense than water so
it's floating and in this one we've got
the deuterium oxide ice so frozen
deuterium oxide and that is denser than
the water so it's sent to the bottom we
did the experiment and the d2 ice did
sink
and it's ain't quite graduating yet but
here's what happened over the course of
the next hour as the d2o began to melt
it gradually the cube began to rise
towards the top of the water have you
any idea why that would have happened I
think what has happened is that the d2o
molecules on the surface of the ice will
have exchanged with hydrogen and I think
also that the melting point of d 2o is
different from that of ice so that you
probably have some melting and reforming
of the ice on the surface so that it
gradually gets less dense and you've got
to remember though if you have a cube
most of the mass is near the outside so
if you change the composition of the ice
on the outside it makes a big difference
for the total weight of the block
obviously is quite a problem how do you
make d2 oh because normally the
deuterium in the water is diluted by a
factor of seven thousand which for
chemists is really pretty dilute
you